[Music]
now they are on top of the world that's
grammy-nominated artist mike posner and
his crew
on top of the tallest mountain in the
world the musician
behind hits like i took a pill in ibiza
reached the summit on mount everest last
week
after announcing the climb exclusively
on cbs this morning
posner's journey helped raise more than
230 thousand dollars
for the detroit justice center he joins
us now with his trainer
and mountain guy john cadrowski this is
his first interview since reaching the
summit good morning congrats to you both
yay thank you
mike that the images are just stunning
what was the feeling like to be up there
uh well first of all i can't talk about
climbing mount everest without talking
about my coach
dr john here and other two guys
that guided me there dawa dorji sherpa
and uh dollar cheering sherpa they're
still in nepal that's where they live
and uh without them is no no everest for
me not even
really a shot so um one it was really
humbling
to be there and uh man just so much
work went into it john trained me for a
year and a half
after i finished walking across america
and so
we we've been through a lot together
that year and a half
and when uh we got to the summit i just
start
i just start crying pretty hard john
john how did mike do you know he was he
was pretty awesome most of the time
what about the other times it was it was
a phenomenal journey it really was
a testament to all the hard work he put
in you know we were
together for about 20 months i kept
saying 20 months for 20 minutes on the
stomach
that's what people don't realize is if
you're lucky to get up there for 20 or
30 minutes after
being on the mound for two months after
climbing over 70 other mounds all over
the world
and so the amount of time and energy put
into it and so i
understood why we both sort of broke
down on the summit with
tears and joy and and all those things
and
the view was incredible right at sunrise
we were just very fortunate
with how it all played out so mike you
were already in pretty good shape when
you took on this challenge you just
walked across america but you say the
biggest challenge was in fact
mental how so
uh man climbing mount everest was a lot
harder
than i thought it was it was
it pushed me to all my limits um
we were there as john mentioned about a
few months
and just base camp did that about 17
500 feet and so
there's really no way to explain to
somebody who hasn't been there
uh what that does to your body you just
don't really
feel good for those entire two months
and the higher we go up just to camp two
you know i don't really sleep up there
and so
by by the just to give you an idea of
how exhausted i was
one when i got down i my body was
emitting smells i had never smelled
you know when we finally got back to
kathmandu i i fell asleep
i think for 36 out of those first 48
hours this is how
exhausted i was
mentally you know it's really hard
john's really good at that
um but you're you're at the whims of the
weather
you know there are certain days you can
climb mount everest and there's others
that it will kill you and so the weather
is
like the weather at home it's always
changing and it's imperfect
and so it is an emotional roller coaster
going from you know hey we're going to
climb today to no we're not
this is all that's part of the journey
as well well
we had some weather too you know it was
very
challenging that there were two cyclones
that came off the bay of bengal
so most seasons the 20th to the 30th you
can climb to the summit
this year we had to wait so it was even
more of a test of patience
but we had drilled that through some of
our other simulations on other mountains
all over the world and so
it was you know mike was ready he was
ready to do it well it's great to see
the two of you sitting side by side
despite the smells that were coming from
mike's body clearly you all still get
along very well so that's good to see
so mike mike i want to know well first
john i want to go to you and then i'll
go to mike
how do you know somebody has what it
takes to do this because i looked at
some of the video
and my jaw fell to the floor when i was
watching what you all were doing
how do you know when somebody can do
this and how did you know mike could do
it
well for me it's kind of a long step
process
i've worked with some clients i've taken
to the stomach before and
when when you work with somebody
sometimes you say it's like well i knew
right away you could do it
but we drill all the skill work whether
it's working with crampons ice axes
doing a lot of other mountains to
prepare you and i kind of told mike hey
he actually told me he said i want to
make sure that i deserve to be there and
i said well
i can get you there if we work on other
things first and then step by step and
if you
quote unquote pass everything that i
have set up for you
we'll go that's what the criteria it
wasn't just
the video is beautiful and mike you it's
no secret how i feel about you and how i
feel about your music
and i'm fascinated by the journeys that
you're always doing are you searching
for something why do you do this
and continue to do it
uh we'll see what happens next but you
know
i was i was on mount everest because i
want to be somebody i'm proud of
you know when i look at myself i want to
go hey that guy is pretty cool
and so that's part of my journey while i
was there
i wanted to be somebody i was proud of
and um
are you somebody are you that person now
are you somebody that you're proud of
it's sort of uh i think the the target
moves and
evolves as i move and evolve but yeah
i'm very proud that
i can't even say i'm really proud of
this i'm more
grateful for this because yeah many
people
helped me and like i said the dollar
cheering dollar door today who we just
got off the phone
we were face time and they're they're in
lucas still
like you know without those guys helping
me i really have a shock to climb this
mountain right
so i just feel blessed yeah i'm glad
you're okay
so mike are you starting training
tomorrow to swim across the english
english channel i mean what's next for
you
it's really interesting when i finished
my walk i talked to you guys
i felt like what's next i want to climb
my eyes let's do this
and i don't feel like that right now i
feel like
give me a dog and a girlfriend you just
stay at home for a while
a dog and a girlfriend don't you mean a
girlfriend and a dog
[Laughter]
and a dog whatever comes first mike it
doesn't matter
backwards in the mountains
well take a rest thanks so much for
joining us this morning congrats again
what an achievement that is mike posner
john cadrowski
and uh sorry before i go um yeah you
know
big i want to do this interview today
was uh i climbed to raise money for the
detroit justice
center that does justice reform work in
detroit my hometown
that's right and uh we could use your
help all your viewers
um if you if you could please donate
whether it whether it's one dollar five
dollars just go to
either mikeposner.com or gofundme.com
everest yeah we mentioned that you
raised two hundred and thirty thousand
dollars
and gayle you get the dog first because
the dog helps you get the girl feel free
yes often that's the case
[Laughter]
all right thank you both